in other news the US and China have
struck a partial trade deal that could
end the 15 month long trade war between
the world's two largest economies Donald
Trump has held talks with China's vice
premier and suspended a tariff hike on
250 billion dollars worth of Chinese
imports now that was set to take effect
on Tuesday it may take more than a month
for a full deal to be written out well
we've come to a deal on intellectual
property Financial Services a tremendous
deal for the farmers a purchase of from
40 to 50 billion dollars worth of
agricultural products another big issue
that we've come to conclusion on is
currency foreign exchange we've also
made very good progress on technology
transfer and we'll put some of
technology transfer in phase 1 phase 2
we'll start negotiations
almost immediately after we've concluded
phase 1 and paper did Jeffrey Wright is
a United States policy analyst at the
Eurasia group now he thinks one of the
reasons behind Trump's decision is to
get some relief for US farmers and to
boost the country's economy I think the
the pieces of this deal that are fairly
concrete are the Chinese agricultural
purchases which Trump says they will
step up above their current levels and
the cancellation of the looming tariff
increase which was due to go into place
next week beyond that there's a lot left
undone around intellectual property a
sectoral opening for financial services
firms in China that has been rumored and
pulled back a number of times and a lot
of other issues where the the real
substance is still needs to be ironed
out the Chinese have already over the
last two weeks or so their purchases of
particularly if soybeans have been at
much higher levels than they were for
the bulk of this summer and so that's a
big relief to farmers and if this deal
holds I think those purchases will will
continue or probably go up as well the
pieces that are left undone are
primarily an intellectual property the
enforcement regime for this deal
as well as a
number of sort of unrelated issues on
national security and particularly on
the huawei the the Chinese telecom firm
it seems pretty clear to me that part of
the reason for his motivation to get
this deal was to get some relief for
farmers and to put a boost into the
macro economy in the US as he heads into
reelection and and comes off of what was
a very damaging week for him politically
here in Washington